hey this you have to see
um a Fox News guest Stacy Washington
serious radio host says that one of the
reasons why we are seeing more
lawlessness in the United States is that
when you go to hotels now they don't
always have those Bibles in the
nightstand
that's the introduction let's listen to
what she said will they be I'll tell you
what will happen because it's New York
unless you basically murder someone you
don't get in trouble here they're in
hoodies they're in masks will we be able
to even find out who did this if we were
they would be either charged as
juveniles or they'd be right back out on
the streets that's right and to
Ainsley's points they see these
businesses they these ones that are open
now are the ones that survived covid
they survived the absolutely
mind-boggling costs imposed upon them by
the government to make sure that they
complied with coveted regulations the
decrease in in customers and customers
because of the the lockdown and the
pandemic now they're finally back on
their feet they're dealing with
heightened taxes from this
Administration they're dealing with zero
foot traffic massive rent payments
because States like this are trying to
make up for the lack of Revenue and just
to get their business destroyed and
potentially their livelihood and one
five minute Fell Swoop so you see the
increase in lawlessness when we take God
out of everything so we're so far down
the Continuum on that and I'm talking
about the fact that if you've stayed in
a hotel anywhere you can't even find a
Bible in the nightstand anymore now
admittedly the Bible is on it's
expensive but it's just a thing that
isn't that amazing so I have to admit I
am partially to blame for there not
being as many bibles in hotel hotel
nightstands anymore when I go into a
hotel
when I look in the nightstand if there
is a Bible there I put it out in the
hallway like your room service tray that
you're done with I take it I don't want
it in the room I admit that I do this
now sometimes I'll put it in the
recycling bin but I my instinct is that
the housekeeping staff probably takes it
out and puts it back in the nightstand I
don't know but my move is to take the
Bible and to put it in the hallway and
then it disappears I just don't want it
in the room with me now what where did
these Bibles come from this goes back to
actually 1899.
um there's a group called The Gideons
International and it was two traveling
sales people Samuel Hill and John
Nicholson and they started you know they
wanted to spread the word of God I guess
to as many people as possible they
thought hotel rooms are the place
because you've got people they're
traveling or whatever they might not
have access to a Bible so you stick a
Bible there and next thing you know
instead of going out and hiring a
prostitute or seeking drugs they'll say
I'm going to stay in and read the Bible
and so on and so forth and so this
started uh sometime between 1899 and
1908 and the Gideon started Distributing
these there are other groups that now do
it as well but Gideon's is the big one
so my move is blame me for it blame me
for the lawlessness I will if I find one
of the Bibles put it in the hallway it's
not part of the hotel room that I am
looking you know double vanity uh rain
shower uh shower head
um free Wi-Fi I'm right there with you a
couple free Fiji Waters maybe I love it
I don't need the Bible in the room with
me so I put it out in the hallway I
guess I'm responsible for the crime wave
in New York City